und dann haben wir uns in den letzten
tagen natürlich alle gefragt ja ist denn
heut schon wieder pandemie ich sage nur
affen pocken das zdf
das zdf hat bereits alle alten folgen
von unser charly aus der mediathek
gelöscht um das infektionsrisiko zu
senken und selbstverständlich das wird
sie nicht überraschen melden sich schon
die ersten sportler zu wort und warnt
vor der affen pocken diktatur oder
behaupten dass bill gates alle orang
utans kippen will
manche von denen scheinen sich
regelrecht zu freuen
die harten brocken sind da
leute der berndes endgültig vor wut
geworden ja
ja
wahrscheinlich waren es schon die ersten
symptome
und natürlich verbietet sich jede
ernsthafte vergleich mit corona dass
affen pockenvirus kennen wir seit über
50 jahren und es gibt längst den
passenden impfstoff will sagen ruhe
bewahren und ganz wichtig auf experten
hören
[Musik]
praxis doktor friedemann
die korona fallzahlen weiter im sinkflug
lauterbach nur noch alle vier wochen bei
lanz und die nächste welle wird erst im
herbst erwartet aus biologischer sicht
sah alles nach einem unbeschwerten
sommer aus doch dann kam das hier
ja diese meldung hat uns soeben erreicht
in deutschland ist der erste fall von
aachen pocken bestätigt worden affen
pocken affen brocken affen poppen müssen
wir uns jetzt auf eine welle des affen
pockenvirus einstellen nein müssen
müssen wir nicht die affen pocken
incidents liegt derzeit bei
null wir erwarten keine neue pandemie
und das ist nicht die einzige gute
nachricht dass gute wenn es überhaupt
was gut ist daran gibt ist dass die
infektion sehr schwer weiterzugeben ist
also man muss ich ja schon richtig
anstrengen ja da muss man sich schon
richtig anstrengen um es zu übertragen
nicht so wie bei mikron da reicht es ja
wenn man an einem vorbei gegen der mit
einem telefonierte der es hatte also wie
läuft denn bei den affen packen die
ansteckung beziehungsweise anstrengungen
jetzt so ab man brauche ich engen
kontakt zu erkrankten oder infizierten
um sich anzustecken dann muss man schon
engen kontakt zu dem mann anders haben
direkter kontakt notwendig über längere
zeit sehr enger schleimhaut kontakt
notwendig also nicht über miteinander
reden längerer intensiver körperkontakt
ohne zu reden sie an was meine kollegen
hier so geschickt umschreiben klick nach
genau fahrten in überfüllten 9 euro
zügen
sollte der ausbruch wider erwarten doch
größer werden sind wir durch die unsere
corona erfahrung zum glück bestens
vorbereitet der schnelltest kriegt
einfach einen dritten strich für affen
poppen das tägliche affen poppen update
macht stadt boston der trigema affe und
im netz heißt der hashtag nicht mehr wir
bleiben zu hause sondern wir treibens zu
hause in zukunft rechnet man leider mit
immer mehr solcher zu losen also
krankheitsübertragung von tieren auf
menschen wie sagte meine oma immer
mensch auf tier das rate ich dir hier
auf personen das gibt infektionen grund
für diese zoonosen ist dass der mensch
dem tierreich immer weiter auf die pelle
rückt und die politik war der nicht
immer ein gutes vorbild ich denke da zum
beispiel an söders stimmenfang versuche
auf kosten unschuldiger tiere oder
natürlich an merkels abschieds vögel
keine angst das heißt jetzt nicht dass
sie ihren hund nicht mehr streicheln
dürfen sie müssen sich nur ausreichend
schützen aber auch wir in den medien
haben in der vergangenheit nicht alles
richtig gemacht manche szenen
hinterlassen durchaus einen verstörenden
eindruck
ja er kuschelt wirklich gerne und riecht
gar nicht mehr so streng wie ich gedacht
hatte
der affe ist mittlerweile leider
verstorben mit oder an affen packen ich
weiß es nicht meine affen
war's 12 risiko begegnung wo weiß denn
gestern ach ja mit der familie im zoo
und damit gute besserung und allzeit
einen milden verlauf tschüss
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbol ihr bei uns im neuen studio
gefunden illuminati freimaurer
staatsführung ist alles dabei dann
wollen wir denn die eigentlichen
strippenzieher bekannt geben
dass so viele abonnenten auf youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten